Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
When creating a video game, an animated movie,
or to create any believable virtual world,
among many other things, we need geometry.
Tons and tons of geometry. Both to store,
and to render images of our
characters and the environment.
And having lots of geometry
means a big headache. You see,
we can use traditional methods that store
all the data needed for these objects,
and they also render super fast. But, there is a
problem. What is the problem? Well, size! These
can take gigabytes that will eat not only your
storage but your cellular data plan as well.
Now, do not despair, modern learning-based
methods are coming to the rescue in the
form of NERFs. That is, Neural Radiance Fields.
Here, we don’t need to store all the geometry,
just a few photos, and miraculously
they can fill in all the missing data,
so … can that really be? Can we fly through
these photos? Yes we can! This is amazing.
Now, it gets better, these are instant NERFs.
These can be trained in a matter of minutes,
sometimes seconds, and rendered also in
seconds. And, look, we are light transport
researchers over here, so our keen eyes see
that specular and refractive objects work
really well too. That is fantastic, and folks
at Luma AI have already made an app that can
create these NERFs right on your phone. And
some of these seem either production quality,
or really close to it. Yes, that’s
right, all this comes from a paper
that was published just two years ago. This
is incredible progress in just two years.
But wait. So, these NERF representations are
much smaller than traditional techniques,
however, they still put some strain on
your cellular data plan. And, don’t forget,
they require considerable
horsepower to render quickly.
But, good news, neural networks are
excellent at compression. For instance,
NVIDIA already has a neural network that can
help us compress even ourselves! You see,
in this earlier work, the technique takes only
the first image from our video, and it throws away
the entire video afterwards! But before that,
it stores a tiny bit of information from it,
which is, data on how our head is moving
over time, and how our expressions change.
That is an absolutely outrageous idea,
except the fact that it works. With this,
our video data for a video call is thus
at least as detailed as the traditional,
state of the art techniques, but uses
a third as much data, or even less!
And, get this in this new paper, scientists at
NVIDIA claim to solve both of our NERFs problems
at the same time! Compact and fast NERFs at
the same time! Now I will believe that when
I see it. Can they put the incredible compression
capabilities of neural networks to more use here?
Let’s see. Whoa, look at that! You see a previous
NERF-based method, and here, the new method. And
can that really be? Am I seeing correctly
or am I dreaming? This new method requires
60 times less data to show us this geometry.
And the quality, as described by the signal to
noise ratio is nearly the same. Not the same,
but very close. And 60x cheaper. My goodness.
And it gets even better. That was just
the compression part. What about the
fast rendering part? Well, these models
are so small, we can start downloading
multiple versions of them at the same time,
and the coarsest version can be shown to us
after receiving only the first 10 kilobytes
of data. That is equivalent to downloading
less than one second of music. Wow. And then,
as more data arrives, the finer details start
to appear over time. And we are through the
whole process very, very quickly. Incredible.
But wait, we are experienced Fellow Scholars over
here, so we know that there are other papers on
this topic. For instance, what about Plenoxels?
How does it compare to that? This is Plenoxels,
which is an amazing paper that we talked
about earlier in this series. By the
way, interestingly, this earlier method did not
use neural networks to achieve what you see here,
which is incredible. And now, look at that! This
new one, look, it can go at least as far with 20
megabytes of data as Plenoxels can go with over a
150. And Plenoxels is not just some ancient paper,
it is from just one year ago. Seeing this
kind of improvement just one year and one
more paper down the line, that is the
power of human ingenuity. I love it.
And you see, this might be the future of imagery.
We don’t store the whole geometry of the objects
anymore, we just take a few photos, and let the AI
fill in the rest. Bravo! What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!